but is it statistic to be looking  forward to the interview now  probably a little bit but yeah  the problem now for black is that  although he's given up a piece he's  actually pinned the white knight it's  just the white pawns they're too strong  and this pawn is just going to run  through and make a new queen uh okay the  black rook is trying to come back and  stop it but this night check is going to  end the game this pawn is simply a  winner  game over prague is going to take the  win now  oh that's so brutal  wow they were tied before this game and  it looks like hans will lose the match  no it's over  he resigns and offers a handshake to  pragnanda who takes another  three-point match win today against hans  niemann to join magnus carlsen on nine  out of nine points so far in the  tournament it's the young pragnanda  there in joint lead with magnus carlsen  in the fdx crypto cup after a great  final game here let's head down to my